oh oh oh oh le foot le foot le foot le
foot le foot le foot y'a plus que ça le
foot le foot le foot le foot le foot
la france est foutue et moi c'est le
bouquet je vis avec un footballeur et en
plus il joue gaulle alors c# pour les
rapports la base les tâches des rebonds
jours c'est ce qu'il ya de bien avec la
phrase et la pêche surtout vu jeudi sa
peine dès qu'il a le dos tourné et rica
beau il plonge pour un oui pour un non
ça m'empêche pas de l'aimer même sur des
petites choses mais je dis baisse toi
ramasser une crotte et fisher pour la
galerie non il faut qu'il plonge et mois
après comme di madre ghz qui se croient
fine essayé avec homo au le foot
l'ambiance à la maison avant les matchs
dans l'hymne fait les sautes carte
moi je ne moufte pas le tni avant la
coupe d'europe il serait bien sûr je
sers dans mes bras il tremblait 1 m 89
quand même enfin ils me disent
d'épouvantables je viens de faire un
rêve dans lequel j'étais une passoire
j écoute bambi qui a été sélectionné
scolaire du lyonnais international
militaire tu vas pas nous faire des
convulsions pour ces bâches une d'élèves
toi et tes mois les penaltys
philippe dorge pata bolt a vu leurs
devoirs laisse toi qui envoie les
penaltys nous voilà dans notre living
premier tir je le prend à contre pied
sans le vouloir bien sûr possessive m'en
fous il détourne du point je peux
prendre la tête but
ne criez pas tu m'a bousculé mois s'est
bousculé moi c'est bousculer notre chien
schéma sherwood
moi j'étais muscu les i carton rose
carton rouge l'appuyer peut être un juge
unique comment tu peux être un juge
juste comme ça monsieur y est monsieur
henri michel qui est d'initier une
succession de michel hidalgo me suis un
michel traîne
enfin j'aime beaucoup son look blond les
cheveux en arrière très sais pas si vous
appelez georges descrières sociétaire de
la comédie française
bref ça et fédérer à l'estragon des
petits rideaux vénitienne avec un
dégradé de courgettes en mai chamelle
bon camby ce cem et je vois bien mon
henri michel sceptiques
rien de plus éthique des soirs dans le
oui avec tabbee jamais des yeux d'une
méchanceté ait avait jamais à cause de
toi je dirais jamais la cage longue de
france alors moi je reconnais je suis
impulsif
jeudi c'était pas à cause de mes chats
mail qu'un petit chat c'est peut-être
pas à cause de la béchamel
c'est peut-être parce qu'ils prennent
pas les passoires
et je pouffe qu'est ce que j'avais pas
fait mouche et il me dit écoute berthe
je m'appelle bertrand et foot berthe
quand un couple 1 arrive à se dire ces
choses là à se déchirer comme ça il vaut
mieux se séparer transfert mois et tout
à coup il lui retranscrire mois
notre siège machine à marquer que le
drame des patchs et nous jouer dans son
équipe
parce que je peux pas dire les noms mais
bon le 2 et avec le 5 le 6 et 7 malgré
la différence d'âge sont ensemble depuis
les gens très gentils très potes ils
sont connus à l'ogcnice ensuite ils ont
muté pour le fc grenoble maintenant ils
sont ici quand n 1 qui dribble l'autre
derrière
un couple sans histoire j'en dirai pas
autant du 8 et du rose du moins depuis
que le président a acheté ce noir
devraient voter d'une bonne le dur comme
toujours je vais leur dire bonjour je
vais serrer quelques mains sur les
douches les abdominaux et dorsaux de
saillé roi total mardi soir 33e minute
du match contre nancy super laissant
duos qui vous dévore toute la défense
adverse et les huit il est marqué dans
les buts c'est celle alors que les
autres y mange pas je n'avale pas les
passes et lui je rêvais toujours le pied
sur le ballon et bien non qu'ils me
rendent d'abord aux cocos nos qui me
rend d'abord au caucus en le foot et ses
pales to bambi
qu'est ce que je vais en faire moi quand
il va être la retraite à 31 ans
comme je dis ami louis sponsors n'ont eu
ni crésus ni bernard tapie tac